a parallelogram is a blank with two sets
of parallel side to two sets of parallel
lines so let's see what the options are
so one option is a quadrilateral and a
parallelogram is definitely a
quadrilateral a quadrilateral is a
four-sided figure and it is definitely a
four-sided figure a parallelogram is not
always a rhombus a rhombus is a special
case of a parallelogram where not only
do you have two sets of parallel lines
as as your sides where two sets of
parallel sides but all of the sides are
the same length in a rhombus and a
square is a special case of a rhombus
where all of the angles are 90 degrees
so here all we can say is that a
parallelogram is a quadrilateral and so
let's check our answer it's always a
good idea to look at hints and so it'll
kind of say the same thing that we just
said but it would say it for the
particular problem that you're actually
looking at let's do a few more of these
Suzanne isn't on it is on an expedition
to save the universe sounds like a
reasonable expedition to go on for her
final challenge she has to play a game
called to find the rhombuses a wizard
tells her that she has a square a
quadrilateral and a parallelogram and
she must identify which of the shapes
are also rhombuses which of these shapes
should she pick to save the universe
so a square is a special case of a
rhombus just to remind ourselves a
rhombus each the opposite sides are
parallel to each other you have two sets
of parallel sides a square has two sets
of parallel sides and it has the extra
condition that all of the angles are
right angles so a square is definitely
going to be a rhombus now all rhombuses
have four sides
so all rhombuses are quadrilaterals but
not all quadrilaterals are rhombuses you
could have a quadrilateral where none of
the sides are parallel to each other
so we won't click this one once again a
parallelogram so up all rhombuses are
parallelograms they have two sets of
parallel sides two sets of parallel line
segments representing their sides but
all parallelograms are not rhombuses so
I would say that
someone gives you a square you can say
look a square is always going to be a
rhombus a quadrilateral isn't always
going to be a rhombus nor is a
parallelogram always going to be a
rhombus we got it right